in this course slobodan will help you
improve your react skills by teaching
you how to build a portfolio website
that has cool javascript animations
if you're looking to build an awesome
react portfolio website you come to a
perfect place in this tutorial i will
show you how to build breathtaking
website with advanced animations using
various techniques like gsap library
animate.css and custom css animations
together we will add a pacman page
loader also i will show you how you can
create and implement contact form using
only email.js library without a need to
set up a server and you will learn to
implement maps on your website and much
much more sounds interesting
please join
wait for me
first thing first let's create react
application using mpx create react app
and pass in the name of the application
in this case it's react portfolio it
will install all the packages that you
need for react application
after project installation is done we
want to change directory to the project
itself and first let's install all the
packages that we're going to be using so
that we can later focus only on coding
and not installing the first package is
email.js which we'll be using to
implement the contact form
so type in mpmi email.js
browser
the next package is for our font icons
so it's at fort awesome
free brands svg icons and we're gonna
install a couple of these font icon
versions
after done clear the console
and the next one is fort awesome slash
free solid svg icons
so we're gonna use the free packages for
fonts
solid icons are going to be used for the
navigation on the left side the next
package is ford awesome slash react
font awesome this is a wrap up for the
font awesome so you can use it easily on
react
the next one is anime.css
it's a css library for animating the
objects and fonts
it's really cool you'll see it
now for more advanced animations we're
gonna use gsapp i'm installing gsab
trial as i didn't want it to create any
accounts
next package is
loaders.css it's a package for loaders
right so we're gonna add a pacman in
between the pages in our application
you'll see it's really cool the next one
is react dashly fleet so on our contacts
page we're gonna have a map and this is
a wrap-up library for using leaflet maps
the next package is react dash loaders
we installed the loaders.css previously
and this is for react integration so
it's really easy to use the loaders
inside of the react
the next one is the standard package
inside of to react is react dash router
dash dom so as we are going to have
three pages in our application this is
going to help us to navigate through
and for styling i'm going to be using
the sas as it helps you to write less
code
and to use some of the operations like
for and variables
and we are finally done with installing
the packages and now i want to open the
project that we just created inside of
the visual studio code
the first thing that i want to add
inside of my root folder is to print
your configuration file
and name of the file is dot pre-tier rc
i'll let this plugin worry about the
formatting and i'm going to worry about
the coding and focus on and the default
settings that i set up is that trailing
commas are going to be enabled tab width
is going to be two
i'm going to remove the semicolons and
add a single quotes
also as we are going to be using scss i
want to update app file
and also update the import inside of the
app component so instead of the app.css
add just has to be sas extension
now let's define some of the global
styles inside of our
file
i'll define primary color to this yellow
ffd700
it's used inside of the animate.css
library so it's needed in order to use
it then import the anime css and let's
define the font faces that we're going
to be using and default font is going to
be helvetica new
and let's enter the url of the font
which is going to be inside of the
assets folder
inside of the fonts folder and the name
of the file is helvetica dash new dot
ttf and format let's add ttf
now let's add the assets folder to our
project and inside of this assets folder
we're gonna have images and fonts and
i'm gonna put the link to the assets
folder in the description so that you
can build entire and same application as
i'm doing here
so okay we have the assets folder now
let's link it inside of our app css file
the rest of the fund families
i'll just copy paste the first font face
three times as we're going to use three
fonts
the next font is going to be named
labelle aurora
we're going to use this phone for
styling the tags on our background
very nice font
and the name of the file is labelled
aurora with camelcase and the format is
buff 2
and the last font is going to be
colverica
and the file name is going to be
colverica rg for regular dash regular
and format is going to be again well f2
and you're done with the font faces
and now i just want to add a default
font for input and text areas
so i'm gonna be using font family
helvetica new
now let's just start our application to
see does it work and have we break
anything until this point
so run npm start from the console
and we have our app up and running
now the next thing which i want to do is
inside of the index.css file i want to
remove some of the predefined styles to
the code
and to change the font family
first i'll define html selector and i'm
going to set the font size to 62.5
percent
for body let's set the 300 as a font
weight eleven as of font size pixels and
1.4 as a line height and a default font
should be helvetica new
as a fallback font we're gonna use sun
serif for the color put the 444
and for the background color the hash
code is 0 2 2 c
4 3.
put the overflow hidden and a display
block
and those should be default values for a
body tag
okay now let's open up a index.js file
and close all the other files
and inside of the index.js file i want
to import browser auto module
and wrap our application around it this
provides us with ability to use the
routes inside of our application next we
can open up the app.js file and this is
the file where i'm gonna be defining our
routes
so remove the boilerplate code
and import the routes from react router
dom
next import a single route and place it
inside of the routes here we're going to
define the first
path which is going to hold the layout
component
and we're going to create that just in a
second
so the element is going to be a layout
but as we don't have this component yet
let's create it
first i want to create a components
folder for all our components and i'm
going to place that inside of the source
directory
now inside of the components
let's create a new folder and name it as
a layout
obviously i'm gonna place layout
component there
then inside of that layout folder add a
new file and call it index.js it's
easier for later on imports
and add index.css file
so this is going to be the pattern that
we're going to use for all of our
components
and the first thing that we want to
import inside of our index.js file is
our scss file so that we don't forget it
later on
all of our components are going to be
functional components so i'm going to
follow the same pattern for every single
component const name layout is equal the
arrow function
here we're just going to create a
boilerplate code so that we can import
it inside of our app file
and export default layout now we can
remove the logo which is from
boilerplate code
and import our layout component
and let's save it and preview it
and we haven't imported the route so
let's do that
and now as we can see it works correctly
so we set up our first component and our
first route
we can start building our layout first
we're gonna build left sidebar so inside
of the components folder
create another folder named sidebar
inside of this folder we want to create
index.js file and
index.scss file
same as we do for other
components close other files so they are
not confusing us and the first thing
that i always do is to import styles on
top of our index.js file
and now let's create a sidebar dummy
component so that we can import it
inside of the layout
so add const sidebar equals a dummy fat
arrow function
and export default sidebar and just put
the text hello from the parentheses
and now we can import that inside of the
layout
and continue building
so inside of the layout index.js file
instead of the hello
just import the sidebar component
and we have connected that as you can
see
remove this dummy text and inside of the
parentheses
we want to add a div with a class name
of a navbar
navbar actually
inside of the nail bar import the link
from react router dom
and edit the name
class name logo
and this is going to be a default home
page so
two is going to route to the slash to
home page
inside of the logo
we want to obviously display the logo so
add the image with the source
and let's import the logo s for slobodan
or slova
so import os from assets folder images
and the name of the file is logo dash
s.png
place the image inside of the source
file
and add alt attribute as a logo
now we want to duplicate the image
and import that new image as well as
we're going to have two images one is
going to be s and the other one is going
to be rest of my name underneath of it
slow but on so let's import both of
these
and let's add to second image logo
subtitle
as it's like a subtitle to our logo and
update the l to slower down
we can't even see our images on the page
as they are too large and they are
overflowing our page
so let's add some styles inside of the
index.scss file
add a class name of navbar
and instead of it
set the background to
181818 it's very dark background
set the width of 60 pixels
height is going to be a hundred percent
position
absolute
top left z index three
set the minimum height to 500 pixels
because on the smaller screens we don't
want to get the overflow on our
container and it's better to have
some scroll bar
so for our logo container set the
display to block and put the padding on
top and bottom to 8 pixels left and
right let it be
and for the image itself
set the display to block
and margin to 8 pixels auto so it's
centered
width to 24 pixels and now we can
finally see it
completely set height to auto
and for our second
image
we want to set the subtitle logo
and set the width to 50 pixels
but i think that we forgot to add
subclass so let's do that
add a class name to our
sub logo and it should work now
and that's our home logo image only so
below that we want to add navigation
with the links to every single page that
we have so add a nav tag
and inside of the knapsack add the nav
link first navlet is going to be our
home page so set the exact to true
active class name to active so that it
helps us to style the active link and
two is going to be slash
inside of our envelope import the font
awesome icon
and for the icon set it for home
it's gonna display nice little home for
the color we want this gray color 4d 4d
for e and it's going to be used for all
our icons
as you can see we got the small house in
our sidebar
now let's copy paste it three times
next link is going to be about section
so for the icon import file user
and put the route to about
also we will need a class so that we can
actually add the content on hover
so add the class name about link
for a third icon is going to be fa
envelope
which is going to be a contact page so
add a class name of contact link
and add to
slash contact
we have our navigation now but it
doesn't work and it also doesn't look
nice so let's add some styles go inside
of the index style file and add an app
tag
inside of the nav tag add these
properties set the display to block
text align its center
position
absolute
set the height to 210 pixels
and we want to position our nav in the
middle so we need to set the top to 50
and on top of that we want to give a
negative margin of
minus 120 pixels
set the width to 100
and for the links
add a font size of 22 pixels
and set the color to
40 4e
which is a gray color set the display to
block
and set the line height to 51 pixel
height is going to be the same 51 pixel
and set the position to the relative
you can see now how it's laid out
and the last thing for nav links we want
to remove the text decoration so set the
text decoration to none
now let's add some transition to our to
our links so for the i set the
transition for all the elements
0.3 seconds is out
and on hover we want to set the color of
our links to yellow
and svg we want to set opacity to zero
so as you can see when we hover over the
svg icon it disappears but we want to
add the content now so instead of the
logo we see the text
so set the after opacity 1. now for all
of our after elements we want to set
some default values set the content to
empty string font size to 9 pixels
set the letter spacing to 2 pixels
for the position property we want to set
an absolute value
bottom set to zero we want to set the
display block and a width of a hundred
percent
text align to center
and we want to set the initial opacity
to zero so that we can fade in in order
to have a smooth transition we need to
add transition property for all set to
0.3 seconds as ease out
and now let's alter the content for the
first child set the content as home
and as you can see when you hover we get
the home text
we can do the same for rest of the links
we can target them using the classes as
we added the class name use the about
link to target the second element and
for the after set the content for about
and as you can see we have the about
link as well now so we can just copy
paste our about link and we can update
the about to contact so let it be
contact link and for the contact to be
contact and now we have all the links
and tags on hover and the last thing
that is left to be done in this section
is to add active class to our active
route link
so add the active class and set the svg
to this yellow color as we are on the
home page the active class gets
activated on the first link and we are
getting active class so we get this
beautiful yellow color
the last part that we want to add to our
navbar is to add the links to our
outside accounts and the profiles like
youtube github linkedin and similar
having that in mind i'll add unordered
list inside of the list i'll add li tag
with an anchor tag again we're gonna use
the icons for links
so the first one is going to be
font awesome for the icon i'm gonna set
the linkedin
the color is going to be the gray color
as we use for our top navigation as well
the target for it is going to be blank
so we want to open the links in the new
page
and we want to set the row
as well
for the href i'm just gonna paste the
link to my linkedin account but
obviously you will use yours and just to
test if the link works correctly i can
open up my page
let's close it now we can just copy
paste over the link that we just created
and update the icons for others and the
links
for the second one i'm gonna use the
github so the icon is f github and i'm
just gonna paste in the link to my
github account the next link is linked
to the youtube channel so add the fa
youtube icon and i'm gonna put the link
to my youtube channel here if you don't
have a youtube account obviously you're
gonna remove this icon
the last link that we're gonna navigate
to is the skype so add the fa skype
icon and update the href with the skype
prefix
after the prefix you want to add a skype
username
everything else is the same so now that
we linked all of our accounts we can
style them to look nicely
first element that we want to target is
our unordered list
so set the position to the absolute and
we want to place it on the bottom of our
screen so bottom position 20 pixels
what is going to be a hundred percent
and we want it to be displayed as block
also set the padding to zero
list style to none we want to remove the
bullet points and align the text to
center
set the margin to 0 as well
the next we want to style are anchor
tags inside of the list items so set the
padding on top and bottom to 7 pixels
and the left and the right side to zero
we want to display them as a block and
to give it a font size of 15 pixel
set the line height to 16 pixels
and the color actually we don't need as
that is set on the icon itself
and when we hover over our links we want
to set the color to be yellow same as we
have on our nav links as well
but we want to do that on the svg so add
svg there please and if we hover over we
can see that we have nice yellow color
and that makes our layout complete on
the left side let's continue with our
home page
but one thing i noticed that if we hover
over our nav links you can actually see
that the font isn't applied this is a
default font and if you go to the
index.css file we can see that i used
font family which is used for a font
name not for the all properties of the
font itself if we save that
we can now see that the font is actually
being applied
so please fix this error if you're
following along
before starting with the content of the
home page i want to add some of the
elements that are going to be used
across our application these elements
are going to be placed in the background
but they're going to add the feel of a
web developer because we're gonna
display on top html and body text and on
the bottom as well
so inside of the layout folder and in
the js file we want to add a class name
with a app so this is going to be the
main wrapper of our application and we
want to add a class name of page and
inside of this element i will set an
outlet where we will render all the
pages
in our application which will be like a
placeholder so import the outlet from
react router dom before the outlet i
already inserted top tags with body tag
now i want to do that for the bottom as
well so we will import the body tags and
we will add a class name of tags
and bottom tags and inside of it i want
to paste in the body code add the break
line and add the html tag as well
so add a class name of bottom text html
so that we can move it slightly and make
a difference of the body tags now i just
paste in the code of the html tags that
i copied over from the web and who
really can remember those characters now
let's add some styles to our tags open
up the index.scss file let's set the
width and the height of the page set for
both of these to a hundred percent and
set the position to be absolute
for our top tags we want to set bottom
position to be set as auto and for top
we want 35 pixels
for tags general class
set the color to be this
this yellow default color that we use
across our application
but i just want to reduce the opacity by
a bit so set it opacity 0.6
position will be absolute and the bottom
will be set to zero
left is going to be 120 pixels
set the font size to 18 pixels and
finally now we can see our body tags and
what we are calling actually
set the font family to a label or this
nice font which will give such a good
styling to our body tags and for our
body tech html i want to add -20 pixel
indentation
so that we actually have that feeling of
the real code
as we have our main layout setup we want
to create a home page finally so inside
of the components folder add a home
folder
inside of the home folder as always add
index.js file and
index.scss file we want to create just a
dummy home component so that we can
import that inside of our router
const home equals hello
and export default home
next we can import our home component
inside of the app.js file so add a new
route with a path
of actually you don't need a path we
just set it as indexed and element is
going to be the home component
now we can bring in some content into
our home page let's do that open up
index.js file inside of the home folder
and remove the implicit return
inside of the curly braces i will add a
return
and inside of the return let's add a div
deal with the class name of container
and a class name of home page
inside the container
i will add a text zone div
this div will contain the animated text
on the left side of our screen
in the text zone
add the h1 title
and inside of the title
add the following text
hi comma then we will add a break
i'm
and after that it should say hi i'm
slobodan for the first letter of my name
i will use an image which will be styled
differently so let's add an image tag
and for the source we're going to import
the image later and for the alt tag add
the developer
image is going to be exactly the same as
we use on the left sidebar so let's
import it import logo title from the
assets images and the file name is logo
dash s.png
and now just place the logo title inside
of the source attribute
okay this is linked properly but it
lacks some styling as you may see
let's continue with building our page
below the image let's add the rest of
the word lobodon with s is going to be
my name slobodan and add the break
and below it's going to say web
developer
and we actually need to surround all the
text that you've written inside of the
h1 title not just the first two words
below this
i will add h2 title
first i said who i am next i want to say
what i do so it's very visible once
somebody lands on your first page so i'm
a front-end developer and javascript
expert and also i create youtube content
as well
and below that we want to add a link
button so this will link to our contact
page so that actually somebody can
contact you in case he has a project for
you full-time job collaboration or he
just wants to say hello two is going to
be slash contact and we're going to add
this to our route later on and class
name add a flat button so we can style
it
now open the index scss file inside of
the layout folder the styles that we're
going to add here are going to be the
same for every single page so we don't
want to duplicate them let's put them
inside of the layout and it will be
applied to all the pages
set the width to be a hundred percent
we'll change the contents
height to ninety percent
min height to 566 pixels
set the position to be absolute and the
opacity to be zero container will have
fade in animation that's why the opacity
needs to be zero at the beginning set it
up to be five percent
margin zero auto
z index to be one transform style
preserve 3d
and animation fade in this is the
animation from
animate.scss duration is one second and
let it end forwards add animation delay
to one second and the rest of the styles
we're gonna place inside of the
index.css file in our home folder
inside of our index.js file in the home
page folder import our index scss file
now we can open our style file and on
top of our file let's add the first
class home page inside of that home page
we want to target h1 tag and inside of
the h1 we have an image
that is overlarged so put the size to 32
pixels and we can finally see the rest
of the h1 title
so target detects zone and position it
absolute
for the left position property put it as
a 10 percent so that we can see it and
it's not positioned below the sidebar
put it up 50 percent as we want this to
be centered as i want our text zone to
be in the dead center add the transform
translate y property and put the minus
50 percent so it moves the text zone a
little bit on top the width is going to
be 40 percent as we are going to have a
60 of the other elements on the right
side and the max height is going to be
90
next let's add some styles to our title
first put the color to be white and you
can see how that stands out now
and let's increase the font size to 53
pixels so it's nice and visible we want
this to stand out when somebody lands on
our index page
put the margin to be zero
and for the fun family put the call
vertica
and for our weight i just want it
slightly to be less bold so the font
weight is going to be 400 as i want this
portfolio to give the user feeling that
he's on a developer portfolio
i want to add h1 tags around our titles
similar what we did for the body and
html tag so we're going to do that with
the before and after of the title
use the content h1 for the font family
again we're gonna use label auror
and color is going to be yellow font
size we want to reduce it to 18 pixels
set the position to absolute
as i want this tag to be slightly on top
of our title
put the margin top
of minus 40 pixels
and place the slight indentation so left
is going to be 15 pixels
and just to fade out a little bit so the
opacity is 0.6
now let's do the similar for the after
as well so content is going to be
closing h1 tags
without the space
fun family is going to be the same
label or
most of the properties are going to be
the same for the h1b4 and h1 after color
is going to be the yellow
the font size
is going to be 18 pixels
position is going to be an absolute
set the margin top to 18 pixels margin
left to 20 pixels
and we want this to animate along with
the text
so put the animation fading one seconds
and delay 1.7 seconds
and backwards
for the fill in mode and for the opacity
is going to be the same 0.6 as for the
b4
let's reload the page to see our fading
animation
that's much better
let's style the rest of our text zone
for the s letter inside of our text
let's add a little bit of space on the
left side so put the margin left of 20
pixels set the opacity of zero because
we will adding the fading animation
actually the rotation animation
height is going to be auto and the
animation is going to be rotate in
one second long linear and fill in mode
both
and for the animation delay i will add
1.4 seconds as you want this animation
to start a little bit after as we are
going to be add some of the loaders
later on
now we can move on on our subtitle set
the color to be ada 80 hash code
set the margin top to 20 pixels
font weight to 400
font size it's going to be 11 pixels
for the fun family let's use good old
sun serif and i want to spread the
letters out so set the letter spacing to
3 pixels
and we will be animating the h2 as well
so put the animation as fade in
one second long
1.8 seconds delay and set the filling
mode as backwards
the last but not the least is our
contact button so use the flat button
class that we use inside of our jsx
set the color to be this default yellow
color font size to 13 pixels font weight
to be 400
for our button i want letter spacing to
be 4 pixels
for the font family let's use good old
sun serif
again we don't want this to be presented
as a link so text decoration set to none
and let me add a little bit of padding
on top and bottom put the 10 pixels and
18 pixels on the left and right side
for the border let's set it to one pixel
solid and our default yellow color
we want a margin top 25 pixels
and to float to left side
now we also want to animate this as well
so put the animation as fade in
animation one second duration 1.8 second
delay and set the filling mode as
backwards actually the name of the
animation is fade in
there you go
and i'll set the white space to no wrap
now let's change the styles on the hover
event so on the hover let's change the
background to be our default yellow
and set the color to be this dark 333
and that completes our tag zone stylings
that's very nice
the next thing which we want to do is to
animate our text so every single letter
needs individually to pop up once the
page is loaded and i would like to
create a component for that so that we
can reuse this component on every single
page and we don't have to repeat this
process
we will just pass in the array of the
characters that we want to be animated
and this function will return the
animated letters
so having that in mind inside of the
components folder create the animated
slatter folder and again create index.js
file and index the scss file
inside of our index file first thing
that we want to do is to import our
styles file as always
next let's define our functional
component
so give it a name animated letters
and this component will receive three
arguments the first argument is going to
be the class that we want to apply to
our characters the second one is going
to be the array of the characters itself
and the last one is going to be the
index the starting point which will
basically set the delay of our letters
and the animation the type of the
element that you want return is going to
be a span as we want it to be an inline
element as these individual letters
needs to form a letter and a word
now let's map to the array of the
letters that we received as arguments we
get the element and the index itself
inside of the map we will return another
span
and we want to give it a key as every
single map inside of the react needs to
have a key index
so we will add a char which is a
basically a letter and an index because
we can have the repeated letters here
as a class name we're gonna pass the
letter class that you receive to the
props and we will add an index plus the
number that is passed through the
properties which is like a starting
point so if the index is 5 every single
index in the map array it will be
increased by 5. and finally this span is
going to display the letter that is
passed in and just export default
animated letters
now we can use it inside of our home
component let's import it there first
let's use the use state hook to define
the state of our class
as letters can only have one animation
and specific moment in time after the
initial loading is done we want to add
animation on hover so this is why we use
use state
default animation name is text animate
the next what i need to do is to create
two arrays for two words that we want to
animate
these arrays need to hold the characters
of the separated letters that we want to
animate for the animated letter
component that we just created
the first array holds the characters
lobodon without the s because s is the
image that we imported
and the second array is going to hold
the web developer
i need to spell it correctly so i don't
make any mistakes
and for the first two words hi i'm i'm
manually gonna add the classes without
using animated letters component
finally replace slobodan word and import
the animated lattice component that we
created for the letter class attribute
passing the letter class variable that
we defined in the use statehook for the
string array attribute pass in the name
array which is lower down the words that
we just defined on top
and for the idx put the 15 number so our
classes are going to start from 15 index
let's open up the console and see does
it work
if you refresh the page and inspect the
letters
you can actually see that every single
letter has text animate it's a single
span and it has different index
nice
now let's do the same for the web
developer part
let's reuse the code that we just coded
out and just replace the string array to
put in the job array and for index
set it to 22.
the last thing that is done is the first
two words so like i said i'm gonna do
that manually
add a spam tag with the h letter in it
for hi
and class name is going to be letter
class that is default class for
animating our letters now we want to
copy over this span and change the class
only the first letter has just text
animate class every next letter has a
delay class as well because we don't
want these letters to appear at the same
time so we are adding the second part
and the index that we are using later on
to add a slight delay to animation so
the letters are appearing in a sequence
so the second letter has the delay of 12
which will be actually 1.2 seconds delay
and copy paste that over to add to two
additional letters
hi i'm
so and we actually need to update
remove this part and update the indexes
to 13 and 14.
as we have classes in place now we want
to add styles to them so open index
style file from the animated letters and
let's add it
default class for text animation is text
animate
so set the display to inline block as we
want this to appear as a word and a
sentence the initial opacity is going to
be zero so we want them to pop out
set the animation as a bouncy end and
duration for this animation let it be to
one second and one second delay if you
want the letters to stay visible set the
animation film mode to forwards and set
the minimum width to 10 pixels so that
they don't jump around
as you can see now all the letters do
appear at the same time so what we want
to do is we want to add a delay to the
indexes that we created and every single
letter is going to appear one by one
we're gonna use for loop inside of the
sas this is a great feature so that we
don't have to manually code classes from
1 to 35 use the loop and go from the
indexes from 1 to 35. inside of the loop
we are creating textanimate class with
underscore and the index from the loop
and we are adding animation delay
animation delay is dividing index by 10
so for every single letter we're getting
10th of a second
and when we refresh our page we can see
that our letters are appearing in a
sequence beautiful animation
after animation is done we want to add
hover effects for our letters so when we
hover over effect we get the yellow
color and also we get the rubber band
effect so let's add that
set the minimum width to 10 pixels so
the text is not jumping around
display to inline block
animation fill mode to both
and finally when we hover over our
characters we want to add animation
rubber band one second and the color to
be our default yellow color
next in the index.js file of the home
folder we can utilize this class so
we're going to use use effect hook
in this effect i'm going to return the
set timeout and inside of the timeout
after 4 seconds
i want to set the class to text animate
hover and i will pass an empty array for
dependencies so this runs only once
and now when we hover over our text we
should get the hover effect let's reload
the page
and for some reason it's not appearing
if we check our index.css file
we can actually see that we are placing
text anime hover as a child of text
animate so let's just place it outside
of it and let's try again
after a couple of seconds for loading
boom we have the hover effects i love it
in order to complete the home page i
want to display the logo on the right
side of the page and animate it using
gsap library so let's create a separate
component for it inside the home folder
create a logo folder and again create
index.js file and index.css file
and let me close all the other files
now inside of the index.js file we want
to import our index style file on top
now i will just create a dummy logo
component so that we can insert that
inside of our home page and continue
with coding define a constant logo which
returns only a hello text and export
default logo
now go to homeindex.js file and let's
import it at the bottom
and automatic import didn't work for
some reason so let's import it manually
just type in import logo from the same
folder logo
and there you go let's build our logo
component now
remove the hello world and insert the
curly braces inside of the curly braces
we want to enter the return statement in
the return we want to create a wrapper
div the name of the wrapper is going to
be logo container in the logo container
we will have two images one will hold
the solid logo image and the other one
is going to be transparent and once the
loading animation is done we want to
display the solid logo
import the solid logo from assets images
and the name of the file is logo s.png
and place that in the source attribute
of our image don't forget to add the alt
attribute and put it s
and next to that i can paste in the svg
outline s logo and all the assets like i
mentioned are going to be in the
description box so that you can build
the entirely same website as i'm
building here now in order to target our
svg element inside of the svg and the g
tag add the class name of the svg
container
all these three elements are going to be
hidden as well svg container svg itself
and the solid image so in order to
manipulate with them and apply gsap
animation to it we need to use use ref
to these three elements one reference is
going to be for the background or rather
container the other one is going to be
for the solid image and the third one is
going to be the outline of the logo now
let's add some stylings to our logo so
it's not overlapping with our text
first let's tile the logo container
class
reset the z-index to zero set the width
to be 400 pixels
set the height to be 60 pixels position
will be absolute position on top of the
element is going to be zero
for the position right i will set 15
percent
it's looking better already
set the bottom to be zero
position left is going to be auto
and set the same setting for the margin
as well
next one is svg
first i want to set the width to be a
hundred percent of the container next
set the height to be automatic bottom
position of the svg is going to be zero
next i want to tilt my logo slightly on
the right side i will use transform
rotate z in order to achieve this and
the rotation value is going to be 30
degrees i'm adding important attribute
so it doesn't get overridden later on
the last piece of the puzzle here is
solid logo set the position as absolute
the top position of the element is going
to be auto
i will use the same value or the right
position and also the same value for the
bottom the only different position
property is going to be the left and it
will take the zero value margin is also
going to be automatic set the width to
be a hundred percent and set the opacity
to be zero as we want the solid image to
appear once the logo animation is done
and again we want to apply same rotation
as we did for the outline logo place the
rotation value as 30 degrees if i remove
the opacity for a second and the
transform rotation value you can see
what it does to our logo if you want our
solid logo to appear on top set the z
index to be 1. now the reason why we
don't see our outline logo is because we
haven't set our stroke settings let's do
that use the svg container class to
target the svg element that we added set
its row color to be our default yellow
color
and set the stroke width to be 10 pixels
and finally we can see it clearly
the last style that we want to add is to
set the opacity 0 to our logo container
as container will have fading animation
now we can switch over to our index.js
file of the home component first add the
logo container ref to our
bgref to our image i want to add a
reference to our solid logo ref
and for the svg path we want to add
outline logograph
next in order to apply our animation
effects we will use use effect hook so
define one on the top for the array of
the dependencies set it as empty array
as i want this to execute only once
library of choice for animations is gsap
so import it from gsab trial and first
we want to register the plug-in for
drawing the animation on the svg next
call the gsap timeline function that
calls the animations in a sequence
called the 2 function which will
represent the end state of the animation
the first argument is the element that
we want to animate so set the background
ref current as the second argument we
can set properties inside of the object
set the duration to be one second and
the opacity as an endpoint to be one
before our function we need to add a dot
and for the draw svg plugin it didn't
work for the automatic import so we need
to do it manually so place it on top
import raw svg plugin from gsab trial
draw svg plugin
and now when the page loads we get the
fade in animation
next i want to chain animation on top of
this current fade in animation so i will
call the from function which is similar
to 2 as it receives the first argument
as the element that you want to animate
in our case it's outline logo svg set
the draw svg property as 0 which is a
starting point and it starts from very
beginning and duration to 20 seconds so
it's going to be a long animation and as
you can see it creates that beautiful
drawing svg animation when the drawing
animation is done i want to fade in the
solid logo so the logo creation
animation is completely done
to achieve that call the gsap from to
function
and as a target element set the solid
logograph
next attribute is the starting point of
the animation and that's opacity zero
and is the third argument is the end
state of our animation which is opacity
1. set the delay to 4 seconds and
duration to 4 seconds
and that finishes up our logo animation
so let's preview it
let's reload the page and see the
complete homepage animation
we have the nice fade in and that
beautiful drawing animation
and when the drawing is done the solid
logo appears and if we refresh again we
can see on the left side that we have
the text pop-up animation
i could refresh this over and over again
outstanding job let's build our next
page
it's going to be an about page
so create new about folder inside of the
components folder
and create again index.js file
and
index.css file
close all the other files and let's
create our about component boilerplate
code
const about equals the function that
returns hello
and just export default about
now in order to use it we need to create
a new route so inside of the app.js
duplicate the new route and set the path
to be slash about
and for the element import the about
component that we just created
and if we click on about link we land on
our new page
first let's import our
index.scss file
remove the hello string add the curly
braces and inside of our component add
the return statement
inside add a first div with a class name
of container and about page and
similarly as on home page we have
another div with a class name of a text
zone where we will place our h1 tag and
a paragraph
inside of the h1 tags we can use our
animated lattice component that we
created for our home page
for the string array parameter we want
to pass in an array of characters
this time it's going to be about me
and for the idx property i want to set
in 15 which actually means 1.5 seconds
delay and just update our import to be
relative to the folder that we are in
and we get our text
below this animated title i will have
three paragraphs as this is about
section i will tell a little bit more
about myself
and now instead of typing all this text
out and torturing you to watch it i
typed it already so i can just copy
paste it i will copy paste three
paragraphs and i will just paste in the
text in the first paragraph i say how
ambitious i am
in the second one i say how confident i
am and from the first two you can tell
that i'm very humble right and the last
paragraph is one sentence definition
now let's add some styles to it so open
index.css file in the layout folder as
this is going to be repeated in the
context page as well
add a very top class about page and
inside of it add a tag zone and this
part will be very similar on the context
page
set the position as absolute set the
left position property as 10 percent so
it's not behind a bar add the transform
translate y property to minus 50
but before we move it on top we want to
add a top property of 50
width is going to be only 35 as we will
have another elements on the right side
of the page set the vertical align to
middle
and the display property to the table
cell
and additionally max height is going to
be 90
next i want to target our title
i will set the font size to 53 pixels
font family will be colverica color of
our main title will be yellow our
default yellow color set the font weight
to 400 so it's not as bold
i will reset the margin top to be zero i
will set position to be relative and
margin bottom to be 40 pixels set the
left position property to 10 pixels
and same as on the home page we want to
add h1 tags before and on the after so i
will use before and after pseudo
selectors on db4 set the content to be
opening h1 tag for the font family again
we will use that label aurora font
let's decrease the font size to 18
pixels
set the position to be absolute so that
we can move it around margin top will
have negative 10 pixels left will have
the same value -10 pixels set the
opacity to 0.6 so it's slightly
transparent and the final style is line
height 18 pixels let's do the similar
for the after pseudo selector
set the content to be closing h1 tag
for the font family you probably guessed
it label or ror
and we want to remove the space on the
closing h1 tag
let's reduce now font size to 18 pixels
and let's adjust the line height
accordingly to 18 pixels as well
again we want to be able to move it
around so set the position to be
absolute
and for the position left property i
want to set to minus 30 pixels
bottom position property will be minus
20 pixels let's set margin left to be 20
pixels
and let's reduce the opacity once again
to 0.6
now let me give some style to the
paragraphs they are barely visible
set the font to be 13 pixels color of
the font is going to be white so we
finally see it for the font family use
good old sun serif
and i want this text to be really thin
so set the font weight to be 300
minimum width of the paragraphs will be
fit content and the paragraphs are going
to have a popping animation so i will
set animation to pulse
and duration is going to be one second
but i don't like the animation where
they pop up at the same time having that
in mind i will add a slight delay to
every single one of them i will use ends
of type selector and for the first
element i will add animation delay to
1.1 second
and when i reload the page you can see
what the animation the first paragraph
has let's do the same for the other two
copy paste the code that we just coded
for two times update the selectors two
and three and animation delays
accordingly to 1.2 seconds 1.3 seconds
let's reload the page to see the final
result
we get this nice animation
and the last thing let's add the class
for the hover effects
the class name seam is on the home page
is text animate hover and this time we
want the color to be white because our
text is by default yellow
the hover effect is not working because
we need to alter the class after initial
animation is done so let's do that as we
did exactly the same thing in the home
index.js file as well let's go and copy
it over copy use statehook from index.js
homepage file
this hook sets the initial value for our
classes and just import it
next let's copy over the use effect hook
in which we use the set timeout to
update the classes after 4 seconds are
done
again we need to import a use of ad hook
i'm using automatic imports now we can
pass our letter class to the letter
class attribute of the animated letters
component and now after the animation is
done the hover effect is here only thing
that i want to update is to set the
delay to 3 seconds as on the about page
we don't have that long loading
animation at the beginning like on the
home page and now let's go the right
part of the about page it will be a cube
with the logos of the skills that i
possess and it will be rotating so add a
div with a class name of stage cube [ __ ]
inside of that create a div with a class
name of cube spinner
cube spinner will hold the six sides of
the cube with just different icons
so let's create a first one with a class
name of face one inside of the phase one
i will have font awesome icon and for
the first icon i'm going to use fa
angular color will be this red dd0031
now copy paste this div five times
then just update the class names to
phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 phase 5 and
phase 6.
now update the icons for the second one
it's going to be fa html5 for phase 3
it's going to be fa css3 for the fourth
one it's going to be fa react
for the fifth one f a j s square for the
javascript for the last one f a get out
for the kit
all these are imported from fourth
awesome free brands svg icons so now
open the index style file for the about
page and let's add some stylings to our
cube
first let's style the stage cube
container set the width to be fifty
percent so it's going to take only the
half of the page set the height to be a
hundred percent and position top to be
zero i will add some padding on top so
set padding top to be eighteen percent
set the margin left to be zero position
property set it to be as absolute
position right property set it to be to
the maximum right so it's a zero value
and the last style is overflow hidden if
we check our cube now it looks like a
list of red icons very small icons so
the next thing that i want to do is to
update the colors of these icons so open
the index.js of the about page and for
the second icon put this hash code
five two nine for the third phase static
hash code to be two eight a four d nine
forty phase four set it to be five e d
four f four
forty phase five
e ef
d8 1d
and the last one
ec4d28
and now every icon in every scale has
their proper color it looks much more
nicer now next open the style file of
the about page and let's continue with
adding the styles to our cube because
right now it's just a list so let's add
the rotation animation actually the
spinning animation cube spinner is going
to hold this animation so set the
animation name to spin cube and let's
define this is going to be a custom
animation that we are going to code
define the animation with add keyframes
and the name is spin cube from property
is going to be empty n2 is going to be
like a starting position so set the
transform rotate x as zero degrees
rotate y
also to zero degrees and rotate z to
zero degrees so like i said this is a
starting point of our animation
on the 16 percent of the animation we
want to transform rotate y to minus 90
degrees
on 33
we want to leave rotate y to minus 90
degrees but we will set rotate z to 90
degrees
on the half of the animation i will copy
over the same styles and for the rotate
y i will update to minus 180 degrees and
for the rotate z i will leave to 90
degrees
on the 66 percent of the animation i
want to copy over again the same styles
and i will just update rotate y to minus
270 degrees
and the last keyframe is 83 percent
where i will set transform rotate x to
90 degrees
next let's add the rest of the animation
properties so that we can trigger the
animation
so for the cube spinner set the
animation timing function to easing out
this will make animation flow very
smooth
next we want to set our cube to be
spinning forever or forever the user is
on the page so set the animation
iteration count to infinite
the animation duration is going to be 12
seconds and after that it's going to
repeat the spin over and over again for
the transform style set the preserve 3d
for the transform origin property set it
to be 100 pixels 100 pixels and 0 and
this will center the rotation of the
animation and for the margin left set it
calculated 50
minus 100 pixels which is the width of
our cube so it's in the dead center of
the right side if we check our animation
now it started the rotation and the
spinning but it misses some of the
styles on the cube itself so it
represents the cube and not the list
let's add those now
let's style the divs inside of the cube
spinner so set the position to be
absolute
the bit property to be 200 pixels and
the height property to have same 200
pixels
add the border to the divs so set the
border one pixel solid ccc which is a
gray color
for the background of the cubes i want
to set the transparent white so set the
background to rgb a
and put the 255
value three times and the opacity 0.4
next we want to align our icons so set
the text align to center and we want to
increase the size so set the font size
to 180 pixels to easily align it
vertically set a display to flex
and in this case actually we don't need
text align setter so set the justify
content to be center for horizontal
alignment and for the vertical one set
the align items to center
also i want our box or cube to glow so
set the box shadow to 0 0 20 pixels
0 pixels and light yellow if we check
the state of our animation right now it
looks much better it resembles more to
the cube but we need to give it some 3d
effect so let's add that
inside of the cube spinner target the
face 1 element set the transform
property to translate z to 100 pixels
we want to separate the elements into 3d
space and i'm targeting z-axis in this
case
next copy paste the same code for 5
times
and updated classes to target phase 2
phase 3 phase 4 phase 5 and phase 6.
now for the phase 2 set the transform
rotate y to 90 degrees and translate z
to 100 pixels
next for the phase 3 set it transform to
rotate y to a 90 degrees
rotate x to 90 degrees as well and
translate z to 100 pixels same as the
previous phase
for the phase 4 div set the transform to
rotate y to 180 degrees
rotate z to a 90 degrees and translate z
to 100 pixels
for the next phase 5d we want to set the
transform to rotate y to minus 90
degrees
rotate z to a 90 degrees and translate z
to 180 pixels
and for the last one the phase 6 copy
over the phase 2 and set the rotate x to
minus 90 degrees translate z will be 100
pixels
and if we check our animation now we get
this beautiful cube spinning with all
the skills that i have in it that's very
nice
now let's add some loading animation for
between the pages
now when we switch between the pages i
want to show the pacman
let's do that first in the about page so
open up the index.js file in the about
folder add a surrounding tags on the
very bottom import the loader component
from react loaders and set the type as a
pacman
next open the app.scss file
and here i will import style for a
pacman loading animation
on the top import tilda loaders.css
source slash animations slash
pacman.scss
now the pacman is loaded but it's
positioned wrongly behind a bar so let's
position it correctly
use the loader active class to set the
display to block
position as absolute
position left will be set to 0
and the position right will have the
same setting zero
to place it in the center set the margin
to auto
next set the top position to zero
and bottom position to zero as well to
align it vertically set the width
property to be 50 pixels and also height
property will be 50 pixels as well
and the pac-man now has correct size and
the placement let's give it a fade-in
animation so set the animation property
to fade out duration 1 second and delay
1 second
animation field mode 2 forwards
and now when we reload the page we get
this pac-man loading animation which
fades out that's very nice let's add it
on the home page as well
so this time open index.js file in the
home folder
and again add a wrapping div and on the
very bottom again import the loader
component from the react loaders and set
the type as a pacman
and that should do it let's preview
and now when we reload the page we can
see that we get the pacman loading
animation and also switching between the
pages about and a home page we also get
the animation i like that now the last
thing on our portfolio website that is
left to be done is our contact page so
let's build that next
close all the files that we opened
in the components folder create contact
folder
in this folder and you know the pattern
already create index.js file and
index.scss file
in the index.js file let's first import
our style file on very top
and let me create a boilerplate code for
a functional component
so constant contact equals to a function
which returns hello
and at the very bottom
export default contact
now we need to create a new route so
inside of the app.js file duplicate the
about route and just update set the path
attribute to be contact and element to
be contact
now we can go back to index component
and let's remove this string add a curly
braces and a return statement
in the contact page same as on the other
two we will have surrounding tags
and we'll have two divs actually one div
and one loader for the div add a class
name of a container and contact dash
page underneath add the loader from
react loaders and again set the type to
a pacman on the contacts page on the
left side i will have tag zone on top
and below that there will be a form
contact form and on the right side of
the page you will have a map with the
location of where i live
let's add the animating text on top
first
so add a div with a class name of text
bash zone
inside similarly like on other pages add
a h1 tag and inside of this stack we
will use animated letters component that
we created previously so it's now really
easy to animate the titles that we use
on our pages automated import didn't
work for some reason so i will manually
import it so import animated letters
from the folder above
animated letters
the first property that we need to pass
in is string array on this page i want
to display contact me so i'm passing as
an array of characters contact me
make sure to put the correct spelling
and make sure to add the space in
between the words
for the index start property let's put
15 which means 1.5 seconds delay of the
animation for altering the animation
class when initial loading is done we
will use again the same code that we
coded on the about and on the home page
so let's just copy it over and now i'm
just using automatic import to import a
used state hook and use effect hook
now we can use the letter class property
that we just created and pass into our
animated letters component
and just like that we have our title
animated but we just need to give it
some styles to position it better and to
make it more visible as we already added
text styles for the about page similarly
like the one we have on the contact page
i will go to the layout styles and just
add contact page and if we reload our
page we can see that the title is done
and animated so our development is
getting faster and faster as we have
done the setup right let's add some
description below
add a paragraph tag and once again i
will just copy paste in the text and you
don't have to suffer watching me typing
that out if we reload the page we can
see that the both of these are animated
already now let's build a contact form
after the paragraph add a div with a
class name of contact form inside of the
div add a form inside of the form add an
ordered list first list item will have
the class name of the half which only
will take the half of the row and inside
of this list item i will place the input
element type will be text
name attribute will be name
placeholder will be named as well and it
will be required
and we got our first field
now let's copy over this list item and
paste it and let's adjust the input to
be email
name also email and placeholder also
email and leave it as required the next
input will be for subject so this list
item will take full row width so we are
not adding class name of half
set the placeholder to subject
type to text
name to subject as well
and this one will be required also
the next list item will hold the message
input and i will be using text area for
it
set the placeholder of the text area as
a message
and looks like that i have a typo here
set the input as a lowercase
add a name attribute to the text area
let it be message
and set it required
and the last list item in our form will
be a submit input
so set a type as a submit
and add a class name of a flat dash
button and set the value of it to send
jsx part is done let's add some styles
first let's target contact form set the
width to be 100
and margin to up to 20 pixels
for the unordered list set a padding to
be zero
and for the margin use the same value
for the list items as well reset the
padding to be zero and set the margin to
be 0 as well
we don't want any bullet points so list
style set to none and set the margin
bottom to 10 pixels overflow will be
hidden display mode as block
position is relative and we want opacity
to be zero as i want this to fade in as
all other elements that we have on this
page and i will set animation to fading
up
two seconds animation and two seconds
delay as i want elements to stay on the
page set the animation fill mode to
forwards
and let's preview our fade in animation
that looks very nice
let's continue with styling the input
elements first for the li half element
set the width to be 49
and let's add some small space on the
left side so margin left set it to be
two percent
set the floating style to be left and
just to mention here i'm refactoring my
code from like seven or eight years ago
so this is why i use the floats these
days i use display flex mostly add the
clear both to li element and for the
half
add the clear none as i want it to be
inline with the other half and set the
first shallow bit to have the margin
left zero so we want only the second
child to have the margin in the space on
the left
next i want to target input type text
and input type email as they don't have
any visual differences only functional
ones
for both of these elements set the width
to be full a hundred percent
and let's remove the borders so put the
border as zero
background of our input elements is
going to be this dark blue
one one
5 1 7 3 hash code
let's increase the size of the elements
so put the height to be 50 pixels set
the font size to be 16 pixels color
needs to have a contrast to this dark
background so set it to be white fff
let's remove the padding on top and the
bottom so set the padding 0 and on the
left and the right side let it be 20
pixels to keep the same width and height
of the element set the box sizing to
border box the next element on the list
is text area which will have the similar
styles like the previous elements and
the inputs set the maximum width to 100
remove the border so value is zero the
background is going to be this dark blue
the same one as we used the previous
inputs height 50 pixels font size 16
pixels again i want contrast for the
color and the background so set the
color to be white fff padding this time
20 pixels on all four sizes minimum
height will be 150 pixels this is the
largest element as it holds the biggest
value and to retain his size set the box
sizing to border box and the last
element is our send button which is not
the least definitely use the flat dash
button css selector and set the first
style of the color to our default yellow
ffd 700 background to 0 0 font size to
11 pixels i want the sliders to be
spread a little bit so set the ladder
spacing to 3 pixels there will be no
text decoration so set it to none
padding on top and bottom is 8 pixels
and on the left and the right side is 10
pixels and let's add the border so set
the border to one pixel solid and our
default yellow color ffd 700 float it to
left side add a little bit of border
radius i'll set to 4 pixels update the
float actually to go to the right side
and our form is done now let's make it
work
for the implementation of our code i
will be using the email.js library the
link to this library will be in the
description and you need to go there and
create an account once you do that you
will get this initialization code which
you can paste in inside of the body tags
only the token will be different
obviously once we finished initializing
our email js library we can get back to
our contact index.js file
first we need to get a reference from
our form so create a const ref form
which equals to use ref hook
now we can pass in this value to the ref
attribute of a form so set the ref to
the ref form and call the unsubmit
method
in the unsubmit event handler i will
call send email function that we will
create just in a minute so before the
return statement add a const send email
and as a parameter it receives an event
i want to stop default submitting so
call the e-prevent default method
in this method we will use our email.js
library so let's import it on top
import email.js from at email.js slash
browser
on the email.js object call the send
form function this function as a first
argument receives service id in this
case it's a gmail as a second argument
it receives a template id and this
template id you get from your account
once you created the account and then
you create a template the third argument
is the form reference and the fourth one
is user token which you get upon
registration once again link to this
library will be in the description below
and after our email has been
successfully sent we want to send a
message to the user so the easiest way
to do that is to use window alert and
what we can do else is to reload our
page so that our form is reseted so call
the window location reload and pass the
argument as false but in case we fail to
send the message again notify the user
that operation failed and they need to
try again
and now we can test it
only thing that i forgot to add is to
call the used wrap hook and now we can
go to our form and test it out i will
just enter some random values for the
testing but as you can see it has
browser validation in place input the
valid email format and fill in all the
required fields in order to be able to
send it and when all that is said and
done
we get the confirmation message that it
has been successfully sent but let's
check my gmail inbox and when i open my
email i can see that i received a
message from email.js
and as you can see subject and email are
there but actually we are missing the
message itself so let's check our form
and yes looks like that we had a typo so
type in message correctly and let's try
again
again fill in all the dummy text so put
test name
test email so this needs to be a correct
format text subject and text message and
submit it
once again we get the confirmation and
let's open our email
and this time we get the message as well
and that's how you can create a form
without need for a backend server you
just need an email.js library in order
to do this
let's continue
on the right side of our contact page i
want to display a map with the position
and the location where i live in for
this purpose i'm using lee fleet maps
we already installed the package i just
need to import the styles inside of the
index file
once again you will be able to find the
link to this library in the description
close the index.html file and get back
to index.js in the contacts folder
before we add a map i want to add a
little box on top with information about
my location so after the text zone add a
div with a class name of info dash map
inside of this div let's add some text
i'm putting my first name and my last
name
and i'm adding a break after that i put
the name of the country where i live in
after that i will put some random street
name with random number after that add
another break tag and after that i will
place a name of the town where i live in
another break and i will add a span
in this pen i will add my real email
address in case somebody wants to
contact me directly next let's add some
styles to our info top
use the info map css selector
set the position of this box as absolute
background color will be completely
black so 0 0 0
set the position top to 50 pixels
position right will be 30 this is going
to be a little bit
off from the center and this box will be
on top of everything so set the z index
to 999999
width will be
267 pixels
set the padding to be 20 pixels on all
four sides to make the complete contrast
set the color to be white so fff for the
font family i will use helvetica
and for the font size set it to 17
pixels i want font weight to be slightly
thinner so set the font weight to 300.
this box will also have fading animation
so set the initial opacity to zero
and set the animation itself to fade in
duration 1 second and delay 1.5 seconds
as i want this box to remain visible set
the animation fill mode to forwards
and the last thing which i want to style
in this box is our span which holds my
email so set the font size to slightly
lower 16 pixels
set the display as block as i want some
separation on the very top add a padding
top to 20 pixels in order my email to
stand out i will change the color to be
our default yellow ffd700
and let's see what we got
and that's exactly what i needed so
let's add the map itself
next to the info map add a div with a
class name of map wrap so this is a
wrap-up for our map next open our index
style file and add some of the styles to
a map wrapper first set the background
property to rgba 8
253 216
and opacity 0.1 this wrapper is going to
be on the right side so set the float to
the right
set the bit to 53 percent and height to
100
and we have our container now with this
greenish color we have already installed
the athlete package but we need to add
some styles to our index.html file links
to the package and the instructions how
to install it again will be in the
description
again open the index.js file in the
contact folder in the map wrap add the
map container component from the react
leaflet library in the center attribute
you will pass in the coordinates where
you want your map to have the center and
for the zoom attribute you will pass in
the level of zoom you want to be applied
by default in the map container add a
tile layer component with the following
url https colon slash slash in curly
braces s dot tile dot open shape map dot
org slash in curly braces z slash
incredibly braces x slash in curly
braces y dot png
this style component is the actual map
component
next to the tile layer i will add a
marker component and know this component
you are importing from rear cliff lead i
will add position attribute and it will
have the same coordinates as the center
inside of a marker let's add a pop-up
and inside of this pop-up let's add some
message for the visitors
slova lives here come over for a cup of
coffee and smiley
now we need to add some styles in order
to see our map and to make it visible so
in the style file of our contact page
add a left fleet container class
set the width property to 100
and the height property as well to the
same value 100
set the position to relative once again
we want this element to fade in so set
the opacity to 0 and now let's set the
animation
animation will be back in right and
duration will be 1 seconds delay 1.2
seconds and as we want our map to stay
on the page set the animation field mode
to forwards and that should be the last
style that we applied on our website
let's see our results and now as you can
see inside of the container we have our
map there's a pin drop with this pop-up
message and the center of the map is my
hometown
and when we reload the page we can see
that fading right animation on the map
and to sum up what we have accomplished
in this hour and a half so we build our
home page where we should impress people
without drawing svg animations and is
popping up text animation we added a
pacman animation to make the page
switching more interesting and on the
about page we can impress people with
this custom made css rotating animation
and the last on the contact page we
added this interactive map and on the
left side we created and implemented
this beautiful form i wanted to make
this tutorial short so i created only
three pages but this tutorial could be
extended to add portfolio page and maybe
optimize it to mobile devices and if you
would like to see the second part of
this tutorial please let me know in the
comments and also please check my
channel for other tutorials like this
one and i spent ton of time to make
these tutorials for you guys so please
spend a couple of seconds to subscribe
and like my video and i see you guys in
the next one